This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. During the 2016 Olympics in Rio de Janeiro, the women's 100 meter freestyle race had a favorite, Australia's Kate Campbell. The swimmer had won two bronze medals at the 2008 Olympics and a gold medal at the 2012 Games. One month before Rio, she broke the world record in the 100 meter freestyle. After that race, she confessed. She didn't really know how she did it. I think the best things you've done for Memphis. I don't remember a whole lot of it.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在2016年里约奥运会期间，女子100米自由泳比赛有一位夺冠热门，那就是澳大利亚选手凯特·坎贝尔。这位游泳选手曾在2008年奥运会上获得两枚铜牌，并在2012年奥运会上获得金牌。在里约奥运会前一个月，她打破了100米自由泳的世界纪录。在那场比赛后，她坦言自己其实并不知道是怎么做到的。我想这是你为孟菲斯做的最好的事情。我记不太清了。
I just remember getting on the blocks and things like stealing good stuff. Once you got a good style, it's all downhill from there. So I think that's pretty much what I did. And then came Rio. Dave and I are going to... because that's pretty much what I did. And then came Rio. At first, it looked like she was going to win. Hey, it started was a little bit slower than everybody else. The point eight of a second was the reaction time. Once she hit the water, look at the world record line
我只记得站在出发台上，感觉就像在偷学好东西。一旦你掌握了好的风格，剩下的就是顺水推舟了。所以我认为我基本上就是这么做的。然后里约奥运会来了。戴夫和我打算……因为我基本上就是这么做的。然后里约奥运会来了。起初，看起来她要赢了。嘿，起步比其他人都慢了一点。0.8秒是反应时间。一旦她入水，看看世界纪录线
on her waist, a great first 50, 24.77. Kate had a commanding lead, but after the 50 meter turn, something happened. Her lead began to evaporate. Oh, look, there's quite a few lining up now. This is not clear, Kavadol. And it's going to be made. In the finals print, other swimmers
在她的腰间，前50米表现出色，24.77秒。凯特曾处于领先地位，但在50米转身后，情况发生了变化。她的领先优势开始消失。哦，看，现在有几个人排上来了。这不清楚，卡瓦多尔。这将会实现。在最后的冲刺中，其他游泳选手
edge past her. She ended up in sixth place. Wow, what a shocking result! Later she said the world got to witness possibly the greatest choke in Olympic history. It turned out, Kate thought she had flinged before the starting gun. It all started. As she hit the water, she was certain she was going to be disqualified. Her race plan went out the window. She panicked.
超过了她。她最终获得了第六名。哇，多么令人震惊的结果！后来她说，全世界见证了奥运史上可能最严重的“崩盘”。事实证明，凯特以为自己在发令枪响前抢跳了。一切都开始了。当她入水时，她确信自己会被取消资格。她的比赛计划泡汤了。她惊慌失措。
She swam the first 25 meters too fast and then ran out of gas on the home stretch. The versions of Kid Story play out all the time for elite athletes across a range of sports. The pressure, the nerves, they can get to even the very best of the best. Yeah, I mean it's a little counterintuitive, right? You want to perform at your best. You know how to do it and you have shown that so many times before. And then all of a sudden, you just can to do it and you have shown that so many times before. And then all of a sudden, you just can't pull it off. This week on Hidden Brain, in the latest in our YouTube.io series, we look at why we choke,
她前25米游得太快，结果在最后冲刺阶段力竭了。凯特的故事在各种体育项目的精英运动员身上不断上演。压力、紧张，即使是顶尖高手也可能被击垮。是的，我的意思是这有点违反直觉，对吧？你想发挥出最好的水平。你知道怎么做，而且之前已经展示过很多次了。然后突然之间，你就是做不到。本周在《隐藏的大脑》中，在我们最新的YouTube.io系列节目中，我们将探讨为什么我们会“崩盘”，
how pressure can hijack our bodies and our brains, and how to keep it from derailing us. All of us have been there, taking the SAT, trying out for the football team, reciting our wedding vows. We all know what it's like to feel hundreds of eyes on us, the pressure, the expectations, the anxiety. Psychologists, Cian Bailock has spent decades studying why many of us crumble under pressure and what we can do about it. Cian Bailock, welcome to Hidden Brain. Oh, thanks for having me. Cian, you've accomplished a great deal in your life. Besides Stellar career as a psychologist, you've also been a prominent administrator.
压力如何劫持我们的身体和大脑，以及如何防止它让我们脱轨。我们都经历过这种情况，参加SAT考试，参加足球队选拔，背诵结婚誓言。我们都知道被数百双眼睛盯着、承受压力、期望和焦虑是什么感觉。心理学家西安·贝洛克花了数十年时间研究为什么我们许多人在压力下会崩溃，以及我们能做些什么。西安·贝洛克，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。哦，谢谢你邀请我。西安，你在生活中取得了巨大的成就。除了作为心理学家的杰出职业生涯外，你还是一位杰出的管理者。
You're currently the president of Barnard College in New York City. But I'd like to take you back to a more humbling moment in your life, if I might. You were in high school and you were a soccer goalie on the California State team. And you were playing a game. Things were going really well until you noticed someone standing right behind you. What happened next? Yeah, I noticed that the national coach, the person that starts selecting for the Olympic team and playing at that national world stage was standing right behind me and all of a sudden I remember that my whole mentality changed. I sort of became hyper aware of everything I was doing and that someone was watching me. I almost was watching
你目前是纽约市巴纳德学院的院长。但我希望能带你回到你生命中一个更谦卑的时刻，如果可以的话。你上高中的时候是加州州立足球队的守门员。当时你正在进行一场比赛。一切都很顺利，直到你注意到有人站在你身后。接下来发生了什么？是的，我注意到国家队教练，那个开始为奥运会选拔队员并能在国家世界舞台上比赛的人正站在我身后，突然间我记得我的整个心态都变了。我变得对所做的一切过度敏感，意识到有人在看着我。我几乎是在通过他的眼睛看着
myself through his eyes. And I ended up really bobbling the next ball that came to me and then eventually I let in an easy shot that I should have been able to block in my sleep. It was almost as if it was in slow motion and I just missed, I dove over the ball rather than at the ball. It was almost like getting the ball shot through your legs when you're playing on the field. And the coach walked away, I watched him walk away
我自己。结果我真的把接下来的球漏掉了，最终我放进了一个简单的射门，我本应该在睡梦中都能挡住的。这几乎就像是慢动作，我只是错过了，我扑向了球的上方而不是扑向球本身。这就像在场上踢球时球从你两腿之间穿过一样。教练走开了，我看着他走开
and I just thought that's it. My soccer career is never gonna be the same and I just couldn that's it. You know, my soccer career is never going to be the same. And I just couldn't understand it. Like, this is something I did all the time. You know, I was a really great player. I practiced so much. Like, why did this change now when he was there? Like, I just, I was confused and mad and sad.
我当时就想，完了。我的足球生涯再也不会一样了，我简直无法理解。就像，这是我一直都在做的事情。你知道，我是一个非常出色的球员。我练习得非常多。为什么当他在那里时，一切都变了？我当时感到困惑、愤怒和悲伤。
Yeah. So we're going to explore and depth what happens inside the brain when we choke and what we can do about it. But I want to begin by clearly laying out the range of ways we can crumble and distress, what sports fans and researchers call choking under pressure. You once experienced this in the academic domain during a chemistry test you took in your freshman year of college. Can you tell me what happens here? in your freshman year of college. Can you tell me what happens here? Yeah, I choked a lot.
是的。所以我们将深入探讨当我们“崩盘”时大脑内部发生了什么，以及我们能做些什么。但我首先想清楚地列出我们崩溃和痛苦的各种方式，也就是体育迷和研究人员所说的“压力下崩盘”。你曾经在大学一年级的化学考试中在学术领域经历过这种情况。你能告诉我这里发生了什么吗？是的，我经常“崩盘”。
I never tested as well as I did in practice. And this certainly happened when I got to college. I went to the University of California at San Diego. I was focused on getting a bachelor's of science majoring in a STEM field. And when I went in to take intro to chemistry, which is a very hard class, at least at what it is for most people.
我的考试成绩从来没有像练习时那样好。当我上大学时，这种情况确实发生了。我去了加州大学圣地亚哥分校。我专注于获得STEM领域的理学学士学位。当我进去参加化学入门课时，这是一门非常难的课，至少对大多数人来说是这样。
And the professor looked around at the 600 person class and said, a lot of you aren't going to pass this class. I thought, oh my god, I'm in that back for sure. Like there's no way. So I paid attention in class. I thought I had studied really diligently for the first test. I took the first test. I walked out, and I remember walking behind a group
教授环顾了600人的教室说，你们很多人都不会通过这门课。我想，天哪，我肯定在那个行列里。这不可能。所以我上课很专心。我以为我为第一次考试学习得非常勤奋。我参加了第一次考试。我走出来，我记得走在一群
of students, and they were talking about the answers. And my answer, I remember thinking, gosh, my answers weren't like their answers. So that was my first cue. Always a bad sign. It was a bad sign. So then he posted, it wasn't like now, where you probably get your scores all online.
学生后面，他们在讨论答案。我记得当时想，天哪，我的答案和他们的不一样。那是我的第一个信号。总是一个坏兆头。这是一个坏兆头。所以后来他贴出了成绩，不像现在，你可能可以在网上查到分数。
But he posted in like, on one of those yellow, legal pieces of paper outside the front door. I think maybe even written in hand. And there were, but at this point, maybe 400 kids in the class. And I got the worst grade out of anyone in the class. I mean, it's really embarrassing. There were a lot of people tied with me, but there was no one below me.
但他把它贴在门外的一张黄色法律用纸上。我想甚至可能是手写的。当时班里大约有400个孩子。我得了全班最差的成绩。我的意思是，这真的很尴尬。有很多人的分数和我一样，但没有人在我之下。
And I remember calling my mom and walking back and saying, a lot of people tied with me, but there was no one below me. And I remember calling my mom and walking back and saying, I can't do college, I'm not good enough. You know, both the domains in which we've talked about, you know, playing, you know, high stress, you know, soccer game and doing a chemistry test, you know, high stress, you know, soccer game, and doing a chemistry test. You know, you could argue that the tasks involved are actually fairly complex and complicated, but sometimes we can choke even when it comes to doing something simple if the stakes are high enough.
我记得给我妈妈打电话，走回去说，很多人和我一样，但没有人在我之下。我记得给我妈妈打电话，走回去说，我读不了大学，我不够好。你知道，我们谈论的这两个领域，你知道，在高压的足球比赛中踢球和参加化学考试。你知道，你可以争辩说所涉及的任务实际上相当复杂和繁琐，但有时即使是做简单的事情，如果赌注足够高，我们也可能“崩盘”。
In 2009, US Supreme Court Chief Justice John Roberts was swearing in President-Elect Barack Obama. Now, both men had spent years in the public eye dealing with difficult and stressful situations. The exact words of the oath of office were not a surprise. They were familiar to both men. But here's what happened during the swearing and ceremony. I Barack Hussein Obama. I Barack Hussein Obama.
2009年，美国最高法院首席大法官约翰·罗伯茨为当选总统巴拉克·奥巴马主持宣誓就职。现在，两人都在公众视野中度过了多年，处理过困难和压力大的情况。就职誓词的准确措辞并不令人惊讶。两人都很熟悉。但这就是宣誓仪式期间发生的事情。我，巴拉克·侯赛因·奥巴马。我，巴拉克·侯赛因·奥巴马。
I Barack Hussein Obama. Do solemnly swear. That I will execute the office of president to the United States faithfully. And I will execute the office of president of the United States faithfully. Can you talk a moment, Sihan, about how sometimes the simplest tasks can trip us up when we're under pressure? Yeah, I think this is why choking is so interesting because it can happen in any sort of situation where we feel pressure to perform well. Something oftentimes that's so well learned that you would be surprised that anything
我，巴拉克·侯赛因·奥巴马。郑重宣誓。我将忠实地执行美国总统的职务。我将忠实地执行美国总统的职务。西安，你能谈谈为什么有时最简单的任务在压力下也会让我们绊倒吗？是的，我认为这就是为什么“崩盘”如此有趣，因为它可能发生在任何我们感到有压力要表现良好的情况下。有些事情往往是如此熟练，以至于你会惊讶于任何事情
would go wrong. The swearing in is a great example of that where maybe the chief just just started paying a little bit too much attention to what he was saying. Just the act of doing that can be really disruptive. One that I like to talk about a lot is parallel parking, which I'm very good at when no one is in the car with me, but when someone is watching, I choke. It's really embarrassing.
会出错。宣誓就职就是一个很好的例子，也许首席大法官开始对他所说的话关注得太多了。仅仅这样做就可能具有很大的破坏性。我经常喜欢谈论的一个例子是平行停车，当车里没有别人时我非常擅长，但当有人看着时，我就“崩盘”了。这真的很尴尬。
You know what I'm believes me, but I'm a really good parallel parker till I'm under stress. It's like one of those philosophical conundrums, right? How do we know you're a good parallel parker? If you're never a good parallel parker, when we can see. Exactly.
你知道，没人相信我，但我是一个非常好的平行停车者，直到我处于压力之下。这就像那些哲学难题之一，对吧？如果我们从未见过你平行停车，我们怎么知道你是一个好的平行停车者？完全正确。
It's all about the tree and the forest. Or even one, I think that's really relevant right now as we come back into social situations is just like interacting with other people. Like, how many times at a party have you tried to introduce yourself and you kind of choke getting the words out or asking someone tells you their name
这完全是关于树木和森林的问题。或者甚至一个我认为现在我们回到社交场合时非常相关的问题，就是与他人互动。比如，在聚会上你有多少次试图介绍自己，结果在说出名字时有点“崩盘”，或者问别人名字时
and you have no idea, even as they're saying it, what it is. Like, we choke in the simplest situations. Yeah, and I want to bring up another example because it's along the lines of what you were just talking about. There are times when we are doing things that we have done hundreds of times before or thousands of times before, and we still can trip up. I'm thinking of US Army
你根本不知道，即使他们正在说，那是什么。就像，我们在最简单的情况下也会“崩盘”。是的，我想提出另一个例子，因为它和你刚才谈论的内容一致。有时我们在做我们已经做过数百次或数千次的事情，但我们仍然会绊倒。我想到的是美国陆军
Buickler Keith Clark who performed taps at President John of Kennedy's funeral at Arlington National Cemetery in November 1963. He'd obviously played it many times before, but something happened when he got to the sixth note. Now you know people later said that the mistake sounded like the bugle was weeping, but Keith Clark himself never got over making this mistake. I suspect that he felt a lot like you felt as you saw the national team coach, you know, walking away from that field. Yeah, I mean, it can be just so devastating to do something that you know how to do and do it not at your level of
号手基思·克拉克，他在1963年11月阿灵顿国家公墓的约翰·肯尼迪总统葬礼上演奏了《熄灯号》。他显然之前演奏过很多次，但当他吹到第六个音符时，发生了点什么。现在你知道人们后来评论说，那个错误听起来像是军号在哭泣，但基思·克拉克本人从未从这个错误中走出来。我怀疑他当时的感觉和你看到国家队教练走开时的感觉很像。是的，我的意思是，做一件你知道怎么做的事情，却在众目睽睽之下没有达到你的能力水平，这可能是毁灭性的。
ability when all eyes are on you. And this is what makes it so mysterious, isn't it? Because when we are going through one of these things, you know, you feel like telling everyone, I really can do it. Believe me, I know how to do this. Yeah, I mean, it's a little counterintuitive, right? You want to perform at your best and you can't, right? It's one thing if you don't care, but choking occurs when you feel the most pressure, you feel everyone's eyes on you, you want to put your best foot forward, you know how to do it, and you have shown that so many times before. And then all of a sudden, you just can't pull it off.
这正是它如此神秘的原因，不是吗？因为当我们经历这些事情时，你会觉得想告诉每个人，我真的能做到。相信我，我知道怎么做。是的，我的意思是，这有点违反直觉，对吧？你想发挥出最好的水平，却做不到，对吧？如果你不在乎是一回事，但“崩盘”发生在你感到压力最大、感到所有人的目光都在你身上、你想展现最好的一面、你知道怎么做、而且之前已经展示过很多次的时候。然后突然之间，你就是做不到。
There are endless examples of professional tennis players and golfers, flubbing simple shots when the pressure is on. Cian soccer story speaks to that. Or take free throws in basketball. So many close games are decided in the final minutes by a player sinking or missing free throws. Right now he's got to go one for two for a tie. You can't describe the pressure here.
职业网球运动员和高尔夫球手在压力下搞砸简单击球的例子不胜枚举。西安的足球故事就说明了这一点。或者以篮球罚球为例。许多势均力敌的比赛都是在最后几分钟由球员罚球命中或投失决定的。现在他必须两罚一中才能追平。你无法描述这里的压力。
I mean, I think free throw shooting is such an interesting aspect of all of my research and it's like, I think, the epitome of a choke situation. Oh, he missed it! Objectively, shooting a free throw is not that hard of a task compared to what basketball players do. It's the same spot. No one is guarding them. They know how to do it. But what
我的意思是，我认为罚球是我所有研究中一个非常有趣的方面，我认为它是“崩盘”情况的缩影。哦，他投丢了！客观地说，与篮球运动员所做的其他事情相比，罚球并不是一项很难的任务。位置是一样的。没有人防守他们。他们知道怎么做。但真正
really changes is the psychological element of it. Two shots here. And that was woefully off the line. But you see how he pulled back Jim. He's missed his last two. He is not staying with the shot. As I said, there's a lot of difference making him when you're up by 20. He keeps it a one possession game. How big is that? But sports also shows us another domain of choking, where the choke isn't over in just a moment, where you let in a goal, but the choke sort of builds on itself. It becomes bigger and bigger. In your book, choke, you tell the story of the French golfer Jean Van Develle at the British Open in 1999. What happened to him, Sia?
改变的是心理因素。这里有两次投篮。那球偏得离谱。但你看到吉姆他是怎么退缩的吗？他最后两次都投丢了。他没有保持投篮姿势。正如我所说，当你领先20分时，罚球和落后时有很大区别。他保持了一球之差的局面。这有多重要？但体育运动也向我们展示了“崩盘”的另一个领域，即“崩盘”不仅仅发生在一瞬间，比如你丢了一个球，而是“崩盘”在某种程度上自我累积。它变得越来越大。在你的书《崩盘》中，你讲述了法国高尔夫球手让·范德维尔在1999年英国公开赛上的故事。他发生了什么，西安？
He got to that 18th hole. He was just ready to win. He's three shots ahead, so he can afford to take a six and still win double-bowgain, still, then it should five over. But you could see, right, when he got to the 18th hole, everything looked a little different. He sat over the ball before he took his first drive, and it did not go well. Oh!
他到了第18洞。他已经准备好获胜了。他领先三杆，所以他即使打出六杆也能赢，双柏忌，仍然，那应该是高于标准杆五杆。但你可以看到，当他到达第18洞时，一切看起来都有点不同。他在第一次开球前坐在球上，结果并不好。哦！
I don't believe this. His first shot on the 18th hole, landed on the fairway of the 17th hole. The second off the grandstand, the third into the water. Look, what is going on here. And you can see the picture that was across newspapers the next day. He took off his socks and shoes and waited into the water. And you can see the picture that was across newspapers the next day. He took off his socks and shoes and waited into the water and was actually going to try and hit the ball out of the water. Now I don't know. We've put many of us have tried these kind
我不相信这个。他在第18洞的第一杆落在了第17洞的球道上。第二杆打到了看台，第三杆打进了水里。看，这里发生了什么。你可以看到第二天报纸上刊登的照片。他脱掉袜子和鞋子，涉水进入水中。你可以看到第二天报纸上刊登的照片。他脱掉袜子和鞋子，涉水进入水中，实际上打算尝试把球从水里打出来。现在我不知道。我们很多人都尝试过这种
of shots, but he's got a sink deeper and deeper. It's all silty down here and I don't think he's. And he thankfully decided not to do that, took the penalty, ended up in a tiebreaker round and lost. This is so, so, so, so sad. But he just crumbled. Not only did his shot start going awry, but you kind of felt like it was building on each other. You had the sense that it was not going in a good direction,
击球，但他陷得越来越深。这里全是淤泥，我不认为他能……谢天谢地，他决定不那样做，接受了罚杆，最终进入了附加赛并输掉了比赛。这真是太、太、太、太令人难过了。但他只是崩溃了。不仅他的击球开始出错，而且你感觉它在不断累积。你有种感觉，它没有朝着好的方向发展，
and it's just heartbreaking. His golfing brain stopped about 10 minutes ago, I think. Yeah, I don't know if you feel the same way as you are, but whenever I see something like this on television or I hear something, I feel terrible. It's like, I feel like, oh my god, I just want this to end. Please fix the problem. And do you feel that way that in some ways you're with them in this moment of excruciating agony? Oh, I feel're with them in this moment of excruciating agony?
这真是令人心碎。我想他的高尔夫大脑在10分钟前就停止工作了。是的，我不知道你是否有同样的感觉，但每当我在电视上看到这样的事情或听到这样的事情时，我都感到非常糟糕。就像，我觉得，天哪，我只想让这一切结束。请解决这个问题。你是否觉得在某种程度上你和他们一起经历了这种极度的痛苦？哦，我感觉
Oh, I feel it with them right there. In a way though, I've learned not only to feel the excruciating pain, but I kind of look at it as a scientist, I'm really interested in what's gonna happen next. Yeah. And I think that's actually one of the reasons we love watching sports, right? We know that people come into professional games often
我和他们感同身受。但在某种程度上，我学会了不仅要感受这种极度的痛苦，而且我开始像科学家一样看待它，我真的对接下来会发生什么很感兴趣。是的。我认为这实际上是我们喜欢看体育比赛的原因之一，对吧？我们知道人们进入职业比赛通常
or amateur games with high skill levels, but you never quite know what's gonna happen when it mistakes are highest. I mean, if you just knew how people were gonna play based on their past records, why would you watch, right? But what's so interesting is that at those highest levels, there's a mental aspect that you just don't know how it's gonna play out.
或业余比赛时具有很高的技能水平，但你永远不知道当赌注最高时会发生什么。我的意思是，如果你只是根据过去的记录就知道人们会怎么打，那你为什么要看呢，对吧？但最有趣的是，在那些最高水平的比赛中，有一种心理层面，你根本不知道会如何发展。
Who's gonna choke? Who's to thrive? Can someone recover? And it's just so fascinating from a human perspective. The thrill of victory and the agony of defeat. I want to talk about a slightly different element of choking. Sometimes when we choke, it can produce breakdowns in communication. For example, in medicine or surgery, or when a team is working on something complex, can you talk about this that sometimes choking is not just about what happens to you, but what happens to you as a member of a team in terms of your interactions with other people on the team?
谁会“崩盘”？谁会成功？有人能恢复吗？从人类的角度来看，这真是太迷人了。胜利的快感和失败的痛苦。我想谈谈“崩盘”的一个略有不同的因素。有时当我们“崩盘”时，它会导致沟通中断。例如，在医学或外科手术中，或者当一个团队正在处理复杂的事情时，你能谈谈这个吗？有时“崩盘”不仅仅是关于发生在你身上的事情，而是关于你作为团队成员在与团队中其他人互动时发生的事情？
Yeah, I mean, I think this is a really interesting aspect of choking. Choking can be very individual, but we often don't work as individuals. You know, often we're working as teams, and one thing that my research and others have shown is that one of the key places that there are performance breakdowns when they're stressful situations, time demands, or there's life or death situations is that people stop communicating as well as they could. And this is really interesting because doctors, for example, they don't communicate all the information to another
是的，我的意思是，我认为这是“崩盘”一个非常有趣的方面。“崩盘”可能是非常个人的，但我们通常不是作为个人工作的。你知道，我们通常是作为团队工作的，我的研究和其他人的研究表明，关键的绩效崩溃点之一是在压力大、时间紧迫或生死攸关的情况下，人们停止了有效的沟通。这真的很有趣，因为医生，例如，他们在交接病人时没有把所有信息传达给另一位
doctor as they hand off a patient, and then there's an issue, or pilots leave something out, or even as you're working as a team on a group project, you fail to communicate in a way that's clear. And what I find so interesting about these situations is that we're often very confident that we've communicated what we need to communicate because we know what it is in our head. But our ability to accurately gauge whether or not someone else understood it is what gets diminished. whether or not someone else understood it is what gets diminished. We often think that people who fail at important tasks are people who don't care, or people who are simply unprepared for the big moment.
医生，然后就出了问题，或者飞行员遗漏了什么，甚至当你作为一个团队进行小组项目时，你未能以清晰的方式进行沟通。关于这些情况，我发现最有趣的是，我们通常非常自信我们已经传达了我们需要传达的内容，因为我们知道脑子里是什么。但我们准确判断别人是否理解的能力却减弱了。我们经常认为在重要任务中失败的人是不在乎的人，或者是根本没有为重要时刻做好准备的人。
When we come back, how choking is often not the product of carelessness and inexperience, but the consequence of expertise and caring too much. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Even the most experienced and skilled musicians, athletes and doctors can sometimes lose it. They crumble unexpectedly and find themselves bewildered at what happened. They know how to do something really well. So why did their skills abandon them when it mattered most?
当我们回来时，我们将探讨“崩盘”通常不是粗心大意和缺乏经验的产物，而是专业知识和过度在乎的结果。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。即使是最有经验和最熟练的音乐家、运动员和医生有时也会失去控制。他们意外地崩溃，并对发生的事情感到困惑。他们知道如何把事情做得很好。那么为什么当最重要的时候，他们的技能却抛弃了他们呢？
See on Bailauk has studied the psychology of choking. She and other researchers have discovered that there is a complex psychology behind this all-too-common experience. In her book, she explores the role of what cognitive scientists call working memory in the phenomenon of choking. I mean, I think about our working memory as like our cognitive horse power, right? It allows us to get lots of things done. Juggle numbers in our head, plan for the future, make decisions based on a lot of different information.
西安·贝洛克研究了“崩盘”的心理学。她和其他研究人员发现，这种极其普遍的经历背后有着复杂的心理学。在她的书中，她探讨了认知科学家所称的“工作记忆”在“崩盘”现象中的作用。我的意思是，我把我们的工作记忆想象成我们的认知马力，对吧？它使我们能够完成很多事情。在脑子里处理数字，为未来做计划，根据不同的信息做出决定。
And the thing that is so important to remember about working memory is that it's limited. We only have so much of it, which is why, for example, it's not a good idea to drive and talk on the cell phone because then part of your working memory is devoted to reacting to what's happening on the road, and another part of it is devoted to the cell phone conversation, and that's not great. Psychologists have come up with a number of ways to identify and test working memory. Can you tell me how they do this, Siyeon? Yeah, well, it's really getting you to work
关于工作记忆，最重要的一点是它是有限的。我们只有这么多，这就是为什么，例如，开车时打电话不是一个好主意，因为那时你的一部分工作记忆致力于对路上发生的事情做出反应，而另一部分致力于手机通话，这并不好。心理学家已经想出了许多方法来识别和测试工作记忆。你能告诉我他们是怎么做的吗，西安？是的，这实际上是让你在思考某事时
as you're thinking about something. So maybe I'll read you a list of digits and you have to repeat them back to me just as I read them. So that's kind of how much you can hold. But what if I read you a list of digits and then you had to repeat them back in the reverse order? Why? That's a lot harder, right?
进行工作。所以也许我会读给你一串数字，你必须像我读的那样把它们重复给我。所以这大概就是你能记住的量。但如果我读给你一串数字，然后你必须倒序重复它们呢？为什么？那难多了，对吧？
Because you have to hold all the digits, then you have to start counting backwards while still not getting rid of any of what you've held. And that's really the working part of working memory. Because working memory is finite, your brain has to quickly decide how to deploy it. In a basketball game, your brain has to take in where your teammates are located, what your opponents are doing. It has to figure out how to respond to a new opportunity that suddenly develops.
因为你必须记住所有的数字，然后你必须开始倒数，同时不能丢掉你记住的任何东西。这才是工作记忆中“工作”的部分。因为工作记忆是有限的，你的大脑必须迅速决定如何分配它。在篮球比赛中，你的大脑必须接收队友的位置、对手在做什么。它必须弄清楚如何应对突然出现的新机会。
One reason skilled players are better than novices is because they have seen similar situations on the court before. So they don't expend a lot of working memory to process what is happening. They can focus their working memory on the elements of the situation that are truly novel. Yeah, I mean, I think that's what really separates those extraordinary performers from us regular ones. Like a concert pianist is not thinking about what their fingers are doing. And because they don't have to think about that, they can then interpret the melody
熟练球员比新手更好的一个原因是，他们以前在球场上见过类似的情况。所以他们不需要花费大量的工作记忆来处理正在发生的事情。他们可以将工作记忆集中在情况中真正新颖的要素上。是的，我的意思是，我认为这才是真正将那些非凡的表演者与我们普通人区分开来的东西。比如音乐会钢琴家不会去想他们的手指在做什么。因为他们不需要去想那个，他们就可以解释旋律
and think about how the tone is in particular situations and have an impact with a piece that you or I who's having to think about our fingers would not be able to. I'm wondering, Cion, if we can talk a moment about the paradox of working memory, because of course, the picture that you're laying out suggests that having working memory is very effective, that it helps us in all kinds of different domains. And of course, on the face of it, that is true, but the answer is also more complicated.
并思考在特定情况下音调如何，并对作品产生影响，而你或我如果必须思考手指的话是做不到的。西安，我想知道我们是否可以谈谈工作记忆的悖论，因为当然，你所描绘的图景表明拥有工作记忆是非常有效的，它在各种不同的领域帮助我们。当然，从表面上看，这是真的，但答案也更复杂。
Can you explain how? Yeah, I mean, so here's really the kicker. It's really important to be able to focus, but you have to be focusing on the right things. And what often happens is that when we're performing skills or activities where it's actually, we've learned them to perfection or learn them on autopilot, it's better not to focus on all the details.
你能解释一下吗？是的，我的意思是，这就是关键所在。能够专注非常重要，但你必须专注于正确的事情。通常发生的情况是，当我们执行那些我们已经学习到完美或学习到自动驾驶状态的技能或活动时，最好不要关注所有细节。
So sometimes our working memory can actually get in the way. And let me just give you an example. Most of us who are fortunate enough could shuffle down the stairs really easily and not give it a second thought. We've learned walking motions and locomotion in a way that we just don't think about what we're doing. But if I ask you to pay attention to your knee and tell me what your knee is doing is your
所以有时我们的工作记忆实际上会阻碍我们。让我给你举个例子。我们大多数幸运的人可以很容易地走下楼梯，而不用多想。我们已经学会了走路的动作和运动方式，以至于我们根本不去想我们在做什么。但如果我让你注意你的膝盖，并告诉我你在走下楼梯时你的膝盖在做什么，你很有可能会从楼梯上摔下来。因为现在我要求你把通常在意识之外运行的东西带入意识注意中。而在这样做时，你可能会花更长的时间思考你的膝盖将如何放置，那就是你摔倒的时候。我想知道这是否可以解释为什么在许多体育运动中，在游戏的一个领域帮助你的东西
shuffling down the stairs, there's a good chance you're going to fall down the stairs. Because now I'm asking you to bring into conscious attention something that normally runs outside it. And you might in doing so, just take a little longer and thinking how your knee is gonna be placed and that's when you fall. I'm wondering if this is what might explain why, in many sports, the same thing that helps you in one domain
实际上会在游戏的另一个领域伤害你。因为实际上我们应该专注、应该集中注意力、应该有意识的时候，在游戏的同一个领域里，帮助你的东西实际上会伤害你。因为实际上，我们应该专注、应该集中注意力、应该有意识的时候，还有其他时候，事实上，有意识和深思熟虑反而会伤害你。是的，我的意思是，我认为那是对的。我甚至会说，你知道，有些事情你需要有意识地去关注，有些事情你不需要，即使在同一个活动中。
of the game can actually hurt you in another domain of the game. Because actually our times when you should be focusing and should be concentrating and should be conscious The same thing that helps you in one domain of the game can actually hurt you in another domain of the game. Because actually, our times when you should be focusing and should be concentrating and should be conscious, and there are other times when, in fact, being conscious and deliberate can hurt you. Yeah, I mean, I think that's right. And what I would even say is that, you know, there are certain things that you need to be conscious and focusing on and certain things that you don't, even within the same activity.
所以你肯定希望你的篮球运动员使用工作记忆来阅读球场，思考接下来的比赛，思考在那之后他们将如何移动，但你肯定不希望球员在那时去思考他们在投篮时如何调整手腕的角度，因为那是他们做得非常流利的事情。这实际上会减慢他们的速度
So you'd want your basketball player certainly to be using working memory to read the court, think about the next play going on, how they're going to move after that play, but you certainly wouldn't want the player at that point to be thinking about how they're angling their wrist as they go to take the shot, because that's something they do so fluently. It's actually going to slow them down
如果必须有意识地去思考它，去使用他们的工作记忆。你在书中写道，关键在于拥有可供支配的大脑能力，但在这种大脑能力成为问题时能够将其关闭。我认为这是一个非常有趣的想法，一方面，你想要拥有这种能力，你想要拥有工作记忆，但你也在某种程度上希望它像一个水龙头，你可以把它关掉，回到自动驾驶状态。我认为那是对的，我认为这回到了这样一个观点，即更多的注意力、更集中注意力并不总是有帮助的。
to have to think about it consciously to use their working memory. You write in the book that the key is to have brain power at your disposal, but be able to turn it off when that brain power is a problem. And I thought that was such an interesting idea that on the one hand, you want to have the ability, you want to have the working memory, but you also want to, in some ways, have it be like a faucet where you can turn it off and go back to autopilot. I think that's right, and I think it gets back to this idea that more attention, concentrating more is not always helpful.
每当我听到教练在边线对孩子们大喊“集中注意力，集中注意力”时，我总是感到畏缩。我的意思是，对于在足球场上看着飞机飞过头顶的孩子来说，这可能是真的。但通常情况下，你知道，在那种压力情况下，你不想鼓励球员对他们不应该关注的事情投入太多的注意力。是的。所以从某种程度上说，我们可以回到你的高中足球比赛。你知道，当你思考教练
And I always cringe when I hear coaches yelling at kids from the side of the line, concentrate, concentrate. I mean, it may be true for the kid on the soccer field who's watching the plane fly above them. But oftentimes, you know, in that pressure situation, you don't wanna encourage the players to pay too much attention to things that they shouldn't. Yeah. So in some ways we can go back to your high school soccer game here. You know, when you were thinking about what the coach
对你的看法时，在某种程度上，当你开始分析自己的行为和表现时，你是在从外部观察自己。我的意思是，这就是你所说的“分析导致的瘫痪”。确实如此。当时我这样做的时候，我有种一切都在慢动作的感觉。我以一种我通常不会的方式在关注。
was thinking of you, in some ways and you started to analyze your own behavior and analyze your own performance, you were watching yourself from outside yourself. I mean, this is what you call paralysis by analysis. It really is. And I think when I did it at the time, I had this feeling of everything going in slow motion. I was paying attention in a way I don't normally do.
直到多年后，当我开始研究这个时，我才意识到这实际上是这些高风险情况下的常见现象。我们太在乎我们在做什么，以至于我们试图控制它以确保最佳表现。不幸的是，这种控制可能会适得其反，实际上破坏了我们流利地在自动驾驶状态下发挥的能力，无法做到我们练习得如此努力的事情。我想谈谈你和其他人进行的一些研究，在这些研究中，你可以诱导人们“崩盘”或看起来像“崩盘”的东西。例如，你进行过研究，要求大学足球运动员
And it wasn't until many years later, when I started researching this, where I realized this is actually a common phenomenon in these high-stakes situations. We care so much about what we're doing that we try and control it in order to ensure an optimal performance. And unfortunately, that control can backfire and actually disrupt our ability to play fluently on autopilot to do the thing we've practiced so hard to do. I want to talk about some research studies that you and others have conducted, where you can actually induce choking or something that looks like choking in people. You've conducted studies where you ask college soccer players, for example,
在运球绕过圆锥体时，注意他们正在使用哪只脚来控制球。告诉我这个研究以及你的发现。是的，我做了很多旨在试图让人们表现更差的研究。但在这种情况下，我们让足球运动员，要么是足球新手或非常缺乏经验的人，运球绕过圆锥体。
to dribble a ball around cones while noticing with side of their feet they are using to control the ball. Tell me about the study and what you found. Yeah, I've done a lot of studies designed to try and make people perform worse. But in this situation, we had soccer players who were either new to soccer novices or just very inexperienced, dribble around cones.
我们还让大学水平的球员或真正的专家球员做同样的事情。我们告诉他们两人都要注意刚刚触球的那只脚的侧面。我们发现，对于专家来说，这样做实际上减慢了他们准确运球绕过圆锥体的能力。但对于新手来说，如果有的话，它甚至还有一点帮助。
And we also had college-level players or really expert players do the same thing. And we told them both to pay attention to the side of the foot that just touched the ball. And what we found is that for the experts, doing that actually slowed down their ability to dribble through the cones accurately. But for the novices, if anything, it helped a little bit.
这回到了这样一个观点，即在大多数情况下，当我们只是在学习一项技能时，我们确实需要对它投入很多注意力。但一旦我们非常了解它并且它处于自动驾驶状态，如果你对你通常不会关注的方面投入太多注意力，大学足球队里没有球员会一边跑一边想左、右、左、右，你实际上会破坏它。这就是工作记忆的伟大悖论。它在我们学习新技能时起着至关重要的作用。当你还是初学者时，深思熟虑和有意识是掌握某事的绝佳方式。
And it goes back to this idea that, for the most part when we're just learning a skill, we do have to pay attention to it a lot. But once we know it really well and it's on autopilot, if you pay too much attention to aspects of it that you wouldn't normally focus on, there's no soccer player in college soccer running down the field thinking about left, right, left, right, that you actually disrupt it. So this is the great paradox of working memory. It plays an essential role as we're learning a new skill. Being deliberate and conscious when you're a beginner is an excellent way
但随着你变得越来越好，它变得越来越自动化。你现在需要的不是工作记忆，而是依赖于所谓的“程序性记忆”。所有你知道如何做得很好的事情都保存在你的大脑程序性记忆中。如果你采取一种已经编码在程序性记忆中的技能，并开始使用工作记忆深思熟虑地思考它，你就会回到像初学者一样的思考方式。这就是你“崩盘”的时候。是的，我的意思是，我认为一个重要的收获是，我们有不同种类的记忆
to master something. But as you get better and better, it becomes more and more automatic. Instead of working memory, you now need to rely on something called procedural memory. All the things you know how to do really well are saved in your brain in procedural memory. If you take a skill that has been encoded in procedural memory and start to think about it deliberately using working memory, you go back to thinking like a beginner. This is when you choke. Yeah, I mean, I think one important take home is that we have different kinds of memory
或者我们以不同的方式谈论记忆。程序性记忆更多地表征了我们对不同程序的记忆，对吧？所以当我们变得非常擅长时，我们不会去想每一步。我们可以一起完成整个程序。我们只是在最后到达。这有点像你每天上班走的路线。当我们曾经通勤上班时，你不会去想你做的每一个转弯。突然之间，你到了工作地点，你就到了那里。
or we talk about remembering in different ways. And procedural memory characterizes more our memory for different procedures, right? And so we don't think about every step as we get really good at it. We can do the whole procedure together. We just sort of get at the end. It's kind of like the route you take to go to work every day. When we did, at one point, commute to work, you don't think about every turn you make. All of a sudden, you end up at work and you're there.
这是一种你已经记住要做的程序。在体育运动中也是如此，随着你变得越来越擅长执行某项特定任务。记忆是，我们称之为程序性记忆，它有点像，你记住了执行它的程序，你可以从头开始，在结尾结束。你不需要去想中间的步骤。研究人员还发现，当我们处于压力之下时，其他认知技能也会受到破坏。在一项研究中，科学家扫描了康奈尔医学院学生在准备执照考试时经历压力的大脑。学生们在简单的认知能力测试中表现不佳。研究人员
And that's sort of a procedure you have memorized to do something. And it's the same in athletics as well as you get much better and better at doing a particular task. The memory is, we talk about it as this procedural memory, it's sort of, you remember the procedures to do it and you can start at the beginning and end at the end. You don't have to think about the steps in between. Researchers have also found that when we are under pressure other cognitive skills get disrupted. In one study scientists scan the brains of Cornell medical students experiencing the stress of preparing for their board exams. The students underperformed in a simple test of cognitive ability. The researchers
追踪了他们大脑内部发生的事情。他们发现，你知道，他们大脑的不同区域并没有像它们应该的那样很好地相互沟通。这几乎就像是处于那种持续的压力下破坏了信息的流畅流动，通常情况下，它导致这些学生，那些准备考试的学生，变得不那么有创造力，不那么能够跳出框框思考，
tracked what was happening inside their brains. And what they found is that you know different areas of their brain were not communicating as well with each other as they should. It was almost as if being under that constant stress had disrupted the fluent flow of information, norally, and it led these students, the ones who are getting ready for the boards to be less creative, less able to think outside the box,
不那么能够解决有趣的问题。西安，我们谈论的很多内容都归结为焦虑在我们生活中所起的作用。你曾经进行过一项关于数学焦虑的研究，并观察了人们在即将开始数学测试时大脑中发生的变化。是的，所以我们最近做了很多工作来研究数学焦虑，因为不幸的是，数学焦虑非常普遍。我们一直对数学焦虑来自哪里非常感兴趣
less able to solve outside the box, less able to solve interesting problems. So much of what we're talking about, Cion, comes down to the role that anxiety is playing in our lives. You once conducted a study into math anxiety and looked at the changes happening in people's brains as they were about to embark on a math test. Yeah, so we've done a lot of work lately looking at math anxiety because unfortunately, math anxiety is really prevalent. And we've been really interested in where math anxiety
以及当一个有数学焦虑的人必须做数学时，实际上发生了什么。我们的论点是，不仅仅是那些对数学感到焦虑的人不擅长数学，而是焦虑本身改变了大脑的功能。所以我们通过邀请那些非常担心数学的人来观察这一点。
comes from and what's actually happening when someone who's math anxious has to do math. And our argument has been that it's not just that people who are anxious about math are bad at it, that something about the anxiety itself changes how the brain functions. And so we looked at that by inviting people who are really worried about math
来自哪里，以及当一个有数学焦虑症的人必须做数学题时，到底发生了什么。我们的论点是，这不仅仅是因为对数学感到焦虑的人不擅长数学，而是焦虑本身在某种程度上改变了大脑的功能。因此，我们通过邀请那些非常担心数学的人来研究这一点
and people who weren't to our lab to have their brain scanned using an MRI. And what was so interesting about this study and about using neuroscience technique here is that we could really separate out what was happening in the brain about being anxious from actually what was going on in the brain when they were doing the math. And you can actually get a picture of which areas of the brain are changing when someone just knows they're about to do math versus when they're actually doing it. And so what we did is we told them they would get a cue, like maybe a yellow square and they knew the math was about to come or they'd get another cue or red square and they knew they were gonna do a reading task. And what we found, which was really interesting,
还有那些来到我们实验室接受核磁共振脑部扫描的人。这项研究以及使用神经科学技术最有趣的地方在于，我们能够真正区分大脑中关于焦虑的部分，以及他们在做数学题时大脑中实际发生的情况。你实际上可以得到一张图像，显示当某人知道自己即将做数学题时，与他们真正开始做题时，大脑中哪些区域发生了变化。我们所做的是告诉他们会收到一个提示，比如一个黄色的方块，他们就知道数学题要来了；或者他们会收到另一个提示，比如一个红色的方块，他们就知道要做阅读任务。我们发现了一个非常有趣的现象，
was when the people who were really worried about math just knew the math was coming, areas of the brain involved in our neural pain matrix, the same areas of the brain that are involved when we pick our finger with a needle or stub our toe were activated. When they just knew the math was coming, they weren't doing any math, they just knew it was coming. But even more interesting was that when these areas of the brain were active, when they just knew the math was coming, when they actually had to do the math, they did worse.
那就是当那些非常担心数学的人仅仅知道数学题要来时，大脑中涉及神经疼痛矩阵的区域——也就是我们被针扎或踢到脚趾时大脑中被激活的相同区域——就被激活了。他们只是知道数学题要来了，并没有在做任何数学题，他们只是知道它要来了。但更令人感兴趣的是，当大脑的这些区域活跃时，也就是他们仅仅知道数学题要来时，当他们真正不得不做数学题时，他们的表现反而更差了。
It's almost as if the pain is now sort of, or the anticipation of pain is sort of crowding out their ability to actually focus on the problem. So at some point now they're not actually looking at the math problem anymore because their brain is so filled with the pain or the fear of the impending pain. And that's really been our argument that people who are anxious about math are not anxious because they're bad at it. They're bad at math because they're anxious about it. And that's a very, very different story
这几乎就像是疼痛，或者说对疼痛的预期，正在挤占他们专注于问题的能力。所以在某种程度上，他们不再关注数学问题本身，因为他们的大脑被疼痛或对即将到来的疼痛的恐惧所占据。这正是我们一直以来的观点：对数学感到焦虑的人并不是因为他们不擅长数学，而是因为他们对数学感到焦虑，所以才表现不好。这是一个非常、非常不同的故事，
about how to help people get better at it. These feelings of anxiety often come from a desire to do well. The solution to choking cannot be to stop caring. When we come back, techniques we can all learn to keep caring, but stop choking. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Psychologist Cian Bylock has found that in high-stakes settings, many of us start to focus on the wrong things. Instead of simply executing what we know how to do, we second-guess ourselves and behave
关于如何帮助人们提高数学水平。这种焦虑感往往源于想要表现出色的愿望。应对“掉链子”的办法不可能是停止在乎。稍后回来，我们将学习一些技巧，让我们既能保持在乎，又能不再“掉链子”。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。心理学家西安·拜洛克发现，在高风险的环境中，我们许多人开始关注错误的事情。我们没有简单地执行我们知道该怎么做的事情，而是开始怀疑自己，并表现出
in highly scripted and stilted ways. Unsurprisingly, we make mistakes. And when we do mess up, our mistakes can then make us even more anxious. To choke might be human, but there are some people who perform remarkably well under pressure. When the stakes are highest, they don't crumble. They actually seem to thrive. Cion is performing well under pressure a matter of temperament or a skill that we can all learn. Yeah well I've really fall strongly on the these are skills that can be learned side. Of course there are many individual
高度刻板和生硬的行为。不出所料，我们犯了错。而当我们搞砸时，我们的错误又会让我们更加焦虑。“掉链子”可能是人之常情，但有些人确实能在压力下表现得非常出色。当风险最高时，他们不会崩溃。他们似乎反而茁壮成长。西安，在压力下表现出色是性格使然，还是一种我们都能学会的技能？是的，我非常坚定地认为这些是可以习得的技能。当然，许多人之间存在个体
differences across people and one is you know maybe how susceptible they are to what other people think about them or how much they care about a particular domain or area but I don't think there's very much evidence at all that people are chokers or thrivers. And I think anyone can learn to perform better at what makes them most nervous when the pressure is on. We talked earlier about that chemistry test in college that you did really badly at.
差异，其中之一可能是他们对他人看法的敏感程度，或者他们对特定领域或区域的关心程度，但我认为几乎没有证据表明人们天生就是“掉链子者”或“茁壮成长者”。我认为任何人都可以学会在压力来临时，在让自己最紧张的事情上表现得更好。我们之前谈到了你在大学里那次考得很差的化学考试。
You came in last in a class of 400. After the test was over, you had a conversation with your mom where you expressed to her concerns about whether you were the right fit for college. And she suggested a number of things to you that turned out to actually be quite relevant in actually turning you from a choker to a driver. What was that conversation like and what did she tell you,
你在400人的班级里考了最后一名。考试结束后，你和妈妈谈了话，向她表达了你是否适合上大学的担忧。她向你建议了一些事情，结果证明这些建议在让你从“掉链子者”转变为“茁壮成长者”的过程中非常有效。那次谈话是怎样的？她对你说了什么，
Sia? Yeah, so I remember calling her as I was walking back to my dorm after getting the score and, you know, I was just devastated and I thought I'd done everything right. But she asked just the right questions. She said, did you study? I said, of course I studied. She said, did you do the practice problems in the book?
西安？是的，我记得考完试后，我一边走回宿舍一边给她打电话，你知道，我当时非常崩溃，我以为我做对了一切。但她问了非常关键的问题。她说，你复习了吗？我说，我当然复习了。她说，你做了书里的练习题吗？
I said, no, I read it just read over the chapters. Then she said, did you have a study group? Did you see if you knew things was like other people knew them? I said, no, I just read over the chapters. And she said, did you have a study group? Did you see if you knew things with like other people knew them? I said, no, I just did it all by myself. She said, did you go to office hours? I said, no, no, I just read the book. Like I did in high school, and I did really well in high school.
我说，没有，我只是读了读章节。然后她说，你有学习小组吗？你有没有看看你掌握的知识是否和其他人一样？我说，没有，我只是读了读章节。她说，你有学习小组吗？你有没有看看你掌握的知识是否和其他人一样？我说，没有，我都是自己一个人学的。她说，你去过答疑时间吗？我说，没有，没有，我只是读了书。就像我在高中时那样，我在高中时表现得非常好。
She said, well, maybe you just didn't study in the right way. And I took her advice to hard. I realized that I had to do something that I didn't like to do, which were the practice problems, which were not fun. And I found a study group, which was helpful to understand what I knew and what I didn't. But when I really figured out how to do this
她说，好吧，也许你只是复习的方法不对。我把她的话听进去了。我意识到我必须做一些我不喜欢做的事情，那就是练习题，这并不有趣。我找了一个学习小组，这对我了解自己掌握了什么、没掌握什么很有帮助。但当我真正弄清楚如何以
in the right way was that I would go to the study sessions having already studied on my own and we'd quiz each other, like trying to get to the answers as quickly as possible. And it was like we were mimicking, taking the test in that group. And that's when I really mastered the problems. And it turns out that that's a really great technique to do well under pressure, is to practice doing well under pressure. And when we took the second test, I got the highest grade in the class.
正确的方式去做时，我会在已经自己复习过之后去参加学习小组，我们会互相提问，就像尽可能快地得出答案一样。这就像我们在小组里模拟考试一样。就在那时，我真正掌握了这些问题。事实证明，这是一种在压力下表现出色的绝佳技巧，那就是练习在压力下表现出色。当我们参加第二次考试时，我得了全班最高分。
Wow. I understand you've helped your own children internalize the same lesson, that in other words, you can actually try and mimic pressure situations before you're actually under pressure in order to help you deal with the situation when it actually arises. Yeah, I mean, I do this a lot with my 10-year-old in terms of if she has to give a presentation in class, I make her give it to me, and sometimes I make funny comments, or I distract her a little bit. I get her used to what it's going to be like in class, and nothing's more pressure-filled
哇。我了解到你也帮助你自己的孩子内化了同样的教训，换句话说，你实际上可以在真正处于压力之下之前，尝试模拟压力情境，以帮助你在情况真正发生时应对它。是的，我的意思是，我和我10岁的女儿经常这样做，如果她在课堂上必须做演讲，我会让她讲给我听，有时我会发表一些有趣的评论，或者稍微分散她的注意力。我让她习惯课堂上会是什么样子，没有什么比
than having your mom embarrass and bother you. So she's ready for it when she gets in front of the group. So in some ways, it seems to me that this is in line with the ideas around how to combat anxiety in general, which is the exposure to the trigger, the anxiety-inducing trigger, is often the best way to reduce our responses to anxiety. How much of this work is connected to the idea
被妈妈尴尬地打扰更让人感到压力的了。所以当她站在小组面前时，她已经准备好了。所以从某种程度上来说，这似乎与关于如何克服一般焦虑的想法是一致的，即暴露于触发因素，即引发焦虑的触发因素，通常是减少我们对焦虑反应的最佳方式。这项工作中有多少与
of exposure therapy? I think there's a common theme that runs right through it. And the idea is that you have to close this gap between training and competition. That's the sports analogy. And you can take that to any skill that you do, any domain, you want to get used to what it's going to be like in the real situation. And so that means, for example, if your child is playing high-level tennis, the first time to show up to watch them
暴露疗法的想法有关？我认为其中贯穿着一个共同的主题。这个想法是，你必须缩小训练和比赛之间的差距。这就是体育类比。你可以将其应用到你所做的任何技能、任何领域，你想要习惯真实情况下的感觉。这意味着，例如，如果你的孩子正在打高水平的网球，第一次去看他们比赛
is not at their big match. They need to get used to you watching them if you're going to show up at practice, right? It means that if you're going to take an SAT or an ACT, you've got to practice taking SATs and ACTs. It means if you're going to speak in public, you've got to practice speaking with other people watching you. You have to get used to what in public, you've got to practice speaking with other people watching you.
不应该是在他们的大型比赛上。如果你打算去练习场看他们，他们需要习惯你在场，对吧？这意味着如果你要参加SAT或ACT考试，你必须练习参加SAT和ACT考试。这意味着如果你要公开演讲，你必须练习在有其他人看着你的情况下说话。你必须习惯
You have to get used to what it feels like and get used to reminding yourself that those physiological responses are not a bad thing. You talk about how there are ways to also reframe those physiological responses. In other words, if you're experiencing sweaty palms or a Palpatating heart, the normal way to interpret those signals is to tell yourself, oh my god, I am overmatched for the situation that I'm in. But there's a different way to also think about the very same symptoms. Yeah, I mean, it's interesting to think about that we'd have the same symptoms whether we were worried or excited, right? And that's really very liberating because then it's about reinterpreting them. And myself and other colleagues have done a lot of work
那种感觉，并习惯提醒自己，那些生理反应并不是坏事。你谈到还有一些方法可以重新定义这些生理反应。换句话说，如果你正在经历手心出汗或心悸，解释这些信号的正常方式是告诉自己，天哪，我无法应对现在的局面。但对于同样的症状，还有另一种思考方式。是的，我的意思是，想到无论我们是担心还是兴奋，我们都会有同样的症状，这很有趣，对吧？这确实非常令人释怀，因为这关乎重新诠释它们。我和其他同事做了大量工作，
showing that when you can get people to reinterpret those symptoms as a sign they're gonna thrive, that beating heart is shunting blood to my brain so I can think, rather than a sign they're gonna fail, they actually perform better. And we've shown this for students taking tests, especially students who are really nervous and anxious about how they're going to do on the test. We've shown that actually just getting them to reinterpret what their feeling leads to better
表明当你能让人们将这些症状重新诠释为他们即将茁壮成长的信号时——那颗跳动的心脏正在将血液输送到我的大脑，以便我能思考——而不是他们即将失败的信号，他们的表现实际上会更好。我们已经为参加考试的学生证明了这一点，特别是那些对考试表现非常紧张和焦虑的学生。我们已经证明，仅仅让他们重新诠释自己的感受就能带来更好的
performance. Cion, you once won an award from the National Academy of Sciences and you had to give a presentation of the academy. You were very tense about it. Can you tell me how you employed some of these techniques to deal with your own anxiety? Right, my family was there. My mom had flown out from California. It was like I knew people were watching online and I was like petrified. My mom and dad used to come watch me talk when I was a young academic, and I hated it. It was like, I was under so much stress.
表现。西安，你曾经获得过美国国家科学院的奖项，你必须在学院做一个演讲。你当时非常紧张。你能告诉我你是如何运用其中一些技巧来应对自己的焦虑的吗？是的，我的家人都在那里。我妈妈从加州飞了过来。我知道人们在网上观看，我当时吓坏了。我年轻时做学术报告，我爸妈经常来看，我讨厌那样。我当时压力太大了。
I have to like physically turn away from my dad because every like frown or, you know, any mouth move and I was like, oh my god, I'm sounding like an idiot. And oftentimes we actually see, ironically, that like friendly faces having your family and friends all there can create more pressure than if you didn't know anyone. And so I reminded myself that my sweaty palms and beating heart were not a bad sign. I also focused on something else which I think is really important is that actually reminding
我不得不从身体上转过身去不看我爸爸，因为他的每一个皱眉，或者任何嘴部的动作，我都会想，天哪，我听起来像个白痴。讽刺的是，我们经常看到，有家人和朋友在场实际上会比不认识任何人时产生更大的压力。所以我提醒自己，我的手心出汗和心跳加速并不是坏兆头。我还专注于另一件我认为非常重要的事情，那就是提醒
yourself why you should succeed. I know the material better than anyone else. Even if everyone in that room is way smarter than me, I know my own material. I'm the master of this. And actually focusing on why you should succeed can lead to better performance. See on another researchers have also identified other techniques to keep athletes and performers in a state of flow where they are relying on their procedural memory rather than their working memory to carry out tasks they have already mastered. One way to keep your working memory from
自己为什么要成功。我比任何人都更了解这些材料。即使房间里的每个人都比我聪明得多，我也了解我自己的材料。我是这方面的专家。实际上，专注于你为什么应该成功可以带来更好的表现。西安，其他研究人员也确定了其他技巧，可以让运动员和表演者保持在“心流”状态，即他们依靠程序性记忆而不是工作记忆来执行他们已经掌握的任务。让工作记忆不
interfering is to give it unimportant things to do just to keep it occupied. Well remember we talked about sometimes we perform poorly under stress, so we start paying too much attention to things that we shouldn't. And one of the ways to stop ourselves from paying attention is to do something else. So counting backwards, singing a song, focusing on one key thought
受到干扰的一种方法是给它一些不重要的事情做，只是为了让它保持忙碌。记得我们谈过有时我们在压力下表现不佳，所以我们开始过多地关注我们不应该关注的事情。而阻止我们分心的方法之一就是做点别的事情。比如倒数数字、唱一首歌、专注于一个关键想法，
and golf people have a swing thought. Or if you're giving a talk, focusing on the three take-home points you want people to get. Anything that takes your mind off of over-analysing every aspect of what you're doing can be really important. Another technique is to focus on your breathing. Breathing slowly and deeply can calm you down.
高尔夫球手有一个挥杆想法。或者如果你在做演讲，专注于你想让人们记住的三个要点。任何能让你不再过度分析你所做事情的每一个方面的事情，都可能非常重要。另一个技巧是专注于你的呼吸。缓慢而深沉的呼吸可以让你平静下来。
But focusing on your breath can also redirect your working memory to something other than what you are doing. Yeah, I mean, the breathing is another, I think, really important technique. It can take your mind off of what you're doing in a way that can be really good. And it can also, again, as you said, calm down your whole body in a way that can be really important. But I tend to think of breathing techniques as a great sort of crutch, just like singing a song or focusing on your pinky toe, anything to take your mind off of what you shouldn't be focusing on in that moment. Do you do this at all, Sian, in your own life? Do you actually try and sing a song in your head or focus on your breathing before you give an important presentation?
但专注于呼吸也可以将你的工作记忆重定向到你正在做的事情之外的其他事情上。是的，我的意思是，呼吸是另一种我认为非常重要的技巧。它能以一种非常好的方式让你从正在做的事情中分心。而且正如你所说，它也能以一种非常重要的方式让你的整个身体平静下来。但我倾向于将呼吸技巧视为一种很好的拐杖，就像唱一首歌或专注于你的小脚趾一样，任何能让你从那一刻不该关注的事情上分心的方法都可以。西安，你在自己的生活中会这样做吗？在做重要演讲之前，你真的会尝试在脑子里唱一首歌或专注于呼吸吗？
I do. So I played lacrosse in college and I was center, so I started the game with the draw, and that was always really nerve-wracking, and I sang Take It Easy by the Eagles. Well, I'm running down the road, trying to loosen my load. I tried not to do it out loud, because people would look me weird. And the song pops into my head now when I get nervous
我会。我在大学时打长曲棍球，我是中锋，所以我以开球开始比赛，那总是非常令人紧张，我唱的是老鹰乐队的《Take It Easy》。好吧，我走在路上，试图减轻我的负担。我尽量不唱出声来，因为人们会觉得我很奇怪。现在当我紧张时，这首歌就会自动出现在我的脑海里，
in situations where I have to perform. It comes in there automatically. Take it easy. nervous in situations where I have to perform, it comes in there automatically. The next time I see you giving a public talk somewhere, I know what song is going through your head right before the talk begins. Exactly. Another thing I do right before a big event is I distract myself, which seems a little bit counterintuitive, but I had argued that 10 minutes before is not the time to cram or to think about exactly how you're going to shoot the shot. It's to do something totally different.
在那些我必须表现的场合。它会自动出现在那里。Take it easy。在那些我必须表现的场合，它会自动出现在那里。下次我看到你在某个地方做公开演讲时，我就知道在演讲开始前你脑子里在唱什么歌了。没错。我在重大活动前做的另一件事是分散自己的注意力，这看起来有点违反直觉，但我认为提前10分钟不是死记硬背或思考你到底要怎么投篮的时候。而是去做一些完全不同的事情。
And I know a lot of professional athletes do this, some listen to music, some do crossword puzzles. I like to read some people know, some like people magazine online, something that just takes my mind off completely of where I'm going. We've talked about how highly trained musicians and athletes can choke. One conclusion you might draw from this is that practice and experience are not very useful in preventing choking. That would be a mistake. I think practice is so important. Practice is really important for developing fluent automated processes and what you're doing. And what the practice does often is allow
我知道很多职业运动员都这样做，有些人听音乐，有些人做填字游戏。我喜欢读一些人知道的东西，比如在线阅读《人物》杂志，做一些能让我完全从即将要去的地方分心的事情。我们谈到了训练有素的音乐家和运动员是如何“掉链子”的。你可能从中得出的一个结论是，练习和经验在防止“掉链子”方面用处不大。那将是一个错误。我认为练习非常重要。练习对于培养流畅的自动化过程非常重要。而练习通常所做的是让你
you not to have to focus on every step and every detail of what you're doing. And if you can do that, when you're playing a game, for example, then you are more likely to perform well. And ironically, you are more likely to perform well. And ironically, you're less likely to remember what you just did. I always make a joke that when athletes are interviewed after a great and fantastic game, all they can do is think their moms. They do that all the time because they don't remember what they did. They don't know what to say.
不必专注于你所做事情的每一步和每一个细节。如果你能做到这一点，例如在比赛时，那么你更有可能表现出色。讽刺的是，你更有可能表现出色。讽刺的是，你不太可能记得你刚才做了什么。我总是开玩笑说，当运动员在精彩的比赛后接受采访时，他们所能做的就是感谢他们的妈妈。他们总是这样做，因为他们不记得自己做了什么。他们不知道该说什么。
I mean, I don't know what to say. I mean, I don't know what to say. And it's because they were performing so automatically, it was actually almost outside of conscious awareness and when you don't pay attention to something, you don't remember it. When you learn a skill can also matter. Cion once conducted a study where she analyzed the age at which golfer started to play the game. So my research and others have shown that when people learn actually really early, they often are protected from choking in these sorts of especially motor skills. It's almost as if they learn it differently, and they're less likely to flub when it matters most.
我的意思是，我不知道该说什么。我的意思是，我不知道该说什么。这是因为他们表现得太自动化了，实际上几乎超出了意识范围，当你不对某事给予关注时，你就不会记住它。学习技能的时间也很重要。西安曾经进行过一项研究，分析了高尔夫球手开始打球的年龄。所以我的研究和其他人的研究表明，当人们在很小的时候学习时，他们通常会受到保护，免受这种“掉链子”的影响，特别是在运动技能方面。这几乎就像他们学习的方式不同，在最关键的时候他们不太可能搞砸。
What do you think is happening in the brain that causes this to happen? We know that oftentimes when children learn activities, they learn them more in a more automatic fashion. They're not thinking about every step of what they're doing. Think about how the kid learns a language, right? It's just sort of seeping in. And sometimes when you learn it in that way, you're sort of protected from essentially being able to unpack it in a way that disrupts your performance.
你认为大脑中发生了什么导致了这种情况？我们知道，孩子们在学习活动时，往往以更自动化的方式学习。他们不会思考自己所做事情的每一步。想想孩子是如何学习语言的，对吧？它只是渗入进去了。有时当你以那种方式学习时，你就会受到保护，免受那种会破坏你表现的拆解式思考的影响。
I'm wondering, Sihan, if you can talk a moment about when you did badly on that chemistry test in college, the thought that went through your mind was not, you know, I prepared for this the wrong way. The thought that went through your mind was, I'm an imposter here. I don't really belong in college. And you have to wonder how often that's happening to other people, people who feel like the pressure has gotten to them and they feel like they're out of place in a situation. Can we talk about the idea that choking can also be shaped by our families,
西安，我想知道你能不能谈谈你在大学那次化学考试考砸的时候，你脑子里闪过的念头不是“我复习的方法不对”。你脑子里闪过的念头是“我是个冒牌货。我不属于大学”。你不得不怀疑这种情况在其他人身上发生的频率有多高，那些觉得压力压垮了他们，觉得自己在某种情况下格格不入的人。我们可以谈谈“掉链子”也可以被我们的家庭、
organizations and cultures? I mean, are there some environments that are more likely to produce choking than others? You know, I think this is really a great question because it hits on an important point that even though we're talking a lot about what's happening inside our head, what's happening inside our head is really affected by the environment that we're in. Right? So if we walk into a situation and we feel like we shouldn't perform well because we've been historically excluded or with the only woman in the room or people don't feel like we should do well. That can have an impact on how we perform.
组织和文化所塑造的想法吗？我的意思是，有没有一些环境比其他环境更容易产生“掉链子”现象？你知道，我认为这是一个非常好的问题，因为它触及了一个重要的点，即尽管我们谈论了很多大脑内部发生的事情，但大脑内部发生的事情确实受到了我们所处环境的影响。对吧？所以如果我们走进一个环境，觉得我们不应该表现出色，因为我们历史上一直被排斥，或者我们是房间里唯一的女性，或者人们觉得我们不应该表现出色。这可能会对我们的表现产生影响。
But if we walk into the same situation and feel like even if we don't do so well, people know that we can learn and get better, that there are examples of people not doing well in the past and being okay, that there is avenues for us to ask questions and not be judged. It all of a sudden can change people's attitude about what they can do. The environment has a big effect on how we feel about ourselves, and in essence, then how likely we are to choke. We interviewed Claude Steele on Hidden Brain some months ago, essence then how likely we are to choke. We interviewed Claude Steele on Hidden Brain some months ago and a lot of his work focuses
但如果我们走进同样的情况，觉得即使我们表现得不好，人们也知道我们可以学习和进步，过去有表现不好的例子，但他们依然很好，有让我们提问而不被评判的途径。这突然之间可以改变人们对自己能做什么的态度。环境对我们的自我感觉有很大的影响，从本质上讲，这也就影响了我们“掉链子”的可能性。几个月前，我们在《隐藏的大脑》中采访了克劳德·斯蒂尔，他的很多工作都集中在
on the idea of stereotype threat, which is that when you have stereotypes about you or your group, in some ways you become more likely to prove those stereotypes true because you're so worried about the stereotypes, so worried about showing that the stereotype is true, that your performance ends up becoming impeded. And in some ways, it's not quite choking, I suppose, but it's sort of a related phenomenon. Yeah, I mean, I've always argued to cloud that stereotype threat is just a form of choking.
刻板印象威胁的概念上，即当你对自己或你的群体有刻板印象时，在某种程度上你变得更有可能证明这些刻板印象是真的，因为你太担心这些刻板印象了，太担心表现出刻板印象是真的，以至于你的表现最终受到了阻碍。在某种程度上，我想这不完全是“掉链子”，但它是一个相关的现象。是的，我的意思是，我一直对克劳德说，刻板印象威胁只是一种“掉链子”的形式。
I think it is. I don't know if he agrees with me, but it is, in my mind, at least, because the environment is essentially having an effect on how you think about yourself in that moment. You want to essentially live down some expectation that someone else has. You're worried about being evaluated
我认为是这样。我不知道他是否同意我，但在我看来，至少是这样，因为环境本质上是在影响你那一刻对自己的看法。你本质上是想消除别人对你的某种期望。你担心被评估，
based on whatever group you come from. And that can affect how you interpret the situation. It can affect what you focus on and can also affect how you interpret your bodily reactions, right? If I have a sweaty palms and beating heart, and I am excited to do something, and I'm ready to go, that will actually lead to better performance.
基于你来自哪个群体。这会影响你如何解读这种情况。它会影响你关注什么，也会影响你如何解读你的身体反应，对吧？如果我手心出汗、心跳加速，并且我为做某事感到兴奋，并且准备好了，那实际上会导致更好的表现。
But if I have a sweaty palms and beating heart, and I'm worried about confirming this stereotype, my performance might actually get worse. So I'm wondering how we should think about what individuals should do. So in other words, I think one of the things that I was picking up as you were talking is that in some ways the deck is stacked unfairly against some people. If you're a first-generation college student, for example, you might be experiencing more pressure being in college than, you know, if multiple members of your family
但如果我手心出汗、心跳加速，并且我担心证实这种刻板印象，我的表现实际上可能会变差。所以我很好奇我们应该如何思考个人应该做什么。换句话说，我想我在听你说话时捕捉到的事情之一是，在某种程度上，对某些人来说，局面是不公平的。例如，如果你是第一代大学生，你可能比那些家族中有多人
have been to college over several generations. And so you're more likely to choke, but it's clear that it's partly the result of structural and environmental factors of which you have no control. But of course, we are relying on individuals in some ways to address those problems because we're locating the problem
几代人都上过大学的人在大学里经历更多的压力。所以你更有可能“掉链子”，但很明显，这部分是结构性和环境因素的结果，而这些因素是你无法控制的。但当然，我们在某种程度上依赖个人来解决这些问题，因为我们将
of choking in individuals. There is some tension there, is there not, between sort of thinking about choking as an individual phenomenon and the problem of choking as a structural phenomenon. Yeah, I mean, I think you're really right. And I think it's an individual phenomenon and how it's mostly been studied,
“掉链子”的问题定位在个人身上。这之间存在某种张力，不是吗？在将“掉链子”视为一种个人现象和将“掉链子”问题视为一种结构性问题之间。是的，我的意思是，我认为你说得非常对。我认为这是一种个人现象，也是它主要被研究的方式，
but it is also a structural phenomenon. And there, in the example you gave, I would argue that it is the organization's responsibility, the College of University, to recognize that that might be the case and to start putting structures in place to help ensure that those students who come in say first generation who might feel as if they shouldn't perform as well have supports so that they can. At Barnard, we just started a whole new office and initiative called Access Barnard. That is for first whole new office and initiative called Access Barnard, that is for first-generation low-income and international students designed to do exactly what you're talking about, which is essentially take some of the extra cognitive load or burden,
但它也是一种结构性现象。在那个例子中，我会说这是组织的责任，即学院或大学，去认识到这可能是事实，并开始建立结构来帮助确保那些进来的学生，比如第一代大学生，可能觉得他们不应该表现得那么好，有支持，这样他们就能表现好。在巴纳德学院，我们刚刚启动了一个全新的办公室和倡议，名为“Access Barnard”。这是为第一代低收入和国际学生设计的，旨在做你刚才谈到的事情，即本质上承担一些额外的认知负荷或负担，
I would argue that they shoulder about not necessarily being as familiar with American higher education. And I would say that, you know, ability is way more widespread than opportunity. And as we think about how to make sure that everyone without ability is able to be at the table and thrive, we have to as organizational leaders and as organizations think about the structures. It can't just be an individual responsibility. can't just be an individual responsibility. I'm wondering, Sihan, if we can talk a moment about some of the work that's looked at
我认为他们肩负着不一定像其他人那样熟悉美国高等教育的负担。我想说的是，能力比机会广泛得多。当我们思考如何确保每个有能力的人都能坐在桌前并茁壮成长时，我们作为组织领导者和组织必须考虑这些结构。这不能仅仅是个人责任。这不能仅仅是个人责任。西安，我想知道我们能不能谈谈一些关注
airline cockpits, for example, compared to 50 or 60 years ago, airline cockpits today are designed to assume that pilots are gonna make mistakes. And the goal of the cockpit is not to say, unless you're perfect, something bad is gonna happen to you. the goal of the cockpit is not to say, unless you're perfect, something bad is going to happen to you. The goal of the cockpit now is to say, we know that things are going to fail from time to time.
飞机驾驶舱的研究，例如，与50或60年前相比，今天的飞机驾驶舱设计假设飞行员会犯错误。驾驶舱的目标不是说，除非你完美，否则坏事就会发生在你身上。驾驶舱的目标现在是说，我们知道事情会不时出错。
We know that pilots are going to make mistakes. The goal of the cockpit now is to minimize those mistakes. And secondly, when the mistakes happen to minimize the consequences of those mistakes, is there a sort of societal implication for this body of work, which is talking about the ways in which we can generally reduce pressure overall? Yeah, I mean, I love this line of thinking.
我们知道飞行员会犯错误。驾驶舱现在的目标是尽量减少这些错误。其次，当错误发生时，尽量减少这些错误的后果。这项工作是否有某种社会意义，即谈论我们可以总体上减少压力的方法？是的，我喜欢这种思路。
I mean, it's sort of like the goal of life shouldn't be that we're not going to make mistakes. It should be that we are going to make mistakes and how do we recover, reduce the impact. And I think that's true in so many situations. So I think the cockpit is a great example. I also think it's true in how people lead organizations. So leaders, for example, talking about the mistakes
我的意思是，这就像人生的目标不应该是我们不会犯错误。而应该是我们会犯错误，我们该如何恢复，减少影响。我认为这在许多情况下都是正确的。所以我认为驾驶舱是一个很好的例子。我也认为这在人们领导组织的方式中也是正确的。所以领导者，例如，谈论他们
they've made, any way that sort of makes it okay for people to make mistakes and learn and grow. And what you wanna be talking about is how can you make it so we're educating people about how to minimize when an accident happens or minimize injury and how to learn from it and how to speak up and know that one mistake is not the end of the world? Do you think that as a society, we also glorify pressure to some extent, Cyan, that in some ways we credit people who are able to do well under pressure as being exceptional.
犯过的错误，任何让人们可以犯错并学习和成长的方式。你想谈论的是你如何能做到教育人们如何尽量减少事故发生时的影响，或者尽量减少伤害，以及如何从中学习，如何大声说出来，并知道一个错误并不是世界末日？西安，你认为作为一个社会，我们在某种程度上也美化了压力吗？在某种程度上，我们将那些能够在压力下表现出色的人视为杰出人物。
I mean, there are clearly situations where you want people who are very good at dealing with pressure. If you're a firefighter, you definitely want firefighters to be able to respond well under pressure because presumably that's when the firefighters are doing their most important work. But there are many situations in life where I feel like we use pressure to test people into professions.
我的意思是，显然在某些情况下，你希望人们非常擅长应对压力。如果你是一名消防员，你肯定希望消防员能够在压力下表现良好，因为据推测，那是消防员做最重要工作的时候。但在生活中，有很多情况下，我觉得我们利用压力来测试人们是否适合某种职业。
And those professions actually don't call for a lot of functioning under pressure, which begs the question of why we're using you know, pressure situations to evaluate people. Yeah, I mean, I think it's a really fair point. What I would argue is that we shouldn't be using anyone situation to decide whether people succeed or whether they can go on or whether they're fit for the job.
而这些职业实际上并不需要很多在压力下的运作，这就引出了一个问题，为什么我们要使用压力情境来评估人们。是的，我的意思是，我认为这是一个非常公平的观点。我会说的是，我们不应该使用任何单一的情况来决定人们是否成功，或者他们是否能继续前进，或者他们是否适合这份工作。
You know, in classrooms, many of our professors at Barnard have stepped away from just having a midterm and a final to multiple assessments throughout the quarter or the semester. It turns out that when you assess people multiple times, they actually learn more because taking a test is also a place to learn what you know and what you don't know. But it also gives a whole or picture, and a more holistic picture. And I think that's true across the board. I mean, I think one reason that job interviews
你知道，在课堂上，巴纳德学院的许多教授已经不再只进行期中和期末考试，而是改为在整个季度或学期进行多次评估。事实证明，当你多次评估人们时，他们实际上学到了更多，因为参加考试也是一个了解你知道什么和不知道什么的地方。但这也能给出一个更全面的图景。我认为这在各个方面都是正确的。我的意思是，我认为求职面试
or these assessment situations are just one shot, is because it's easier to do it that way. But the question is, does easier lead you essentially to the best outcome? And I think oftentimes the answer is no. [♪ Music playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, the brain reveal about getting it right when you have to. See you on Bylock. Thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Oh, it was so fun. Thank you.
或这些评估情况只是一次性的原因之一，是因为那样做更容易。但问题是，更容易是否能让你从本质上获得最好的结果？我认为答案往往是否定的。[背景音乐播放，大脑揭示了当你必须做对时该如何做。西安·拜洛克。非常感谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。哦，这太有趣了。谢谢。
Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Laura Quarelle, Kristen Wong, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. For today's Anson Quiro, we turn the mic over to you, our listeners, with a story from our show, My Anson Quiro. Today's My Anson Quiro is brought to you by Anstar. Anstar advisors are now with you everywhere on the app, in your car and at home.
《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲-保罗、劳拉·夸雷尔、克里斯汀·王、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。今天的“安森·奎罗”环节，我们将麦克风交给你们，我们的听众，分享我们节目中的一个故事，我的“安森·奎罗”。今天的“我的安森·奎罗”由安星赞助。安星顾问现在在应用程序、你的车里和家里随时陪伴着你。
Our story comes from 14-year-old Lila Hafa. For as long as she can remember, Lila has struggled to express herself in writing. Her handwriting is sometimes messy and disorganized and she used to have trouble holding a pen in she can remember, Lila has struggled to express herself in writing. Her handwriting is sometimes messy and disorganized and she used to have trouble holding a pen in her first year in school. Her teachers didn't seem to notice that anything was wrong, but that changed when she got to third grade and she had a teacher named Valerie Homgren. I will never forget one day when I was having trouble doing an assignment. I was starting to write in the middle of the page, not on the left hand side like I was supposed to. My writing was sloppy and the words ran into each other and the lines ran into each other.
我们的故事来自14岁的莱拉·哈法。从她记事起，莱拉就一直在写作表达自己方面挣扎。她的笔迹有时凌乱且杂乱无章，她过去在学校的第一年里拿笔都有困难。她的老师似乎没有注意到有什么不对劲，但当她上三年级时，情况发生了变化，她有一位名叫瓦莱丽·霍姆格伦的老师。我永远不会忘记有一天我在做作业时遇到困难。我开始在页面中间写，而不是像我应该做的那样在左侧写。我的字迹很潦草，单词连在一起，线条也连在一起。
I went up to her to see if I could get some help on this. So Miss Homegrown realized that there was something going on and she said that I seemed to be spelling at a second grade level because I was in third grade. I said that I felt more like I was spelling at a kindergarten level. And I think that in that instance and in other instances that she realized that there was something more going on than just the typical rating problems. Lila had some test done and she was diagnosed with a learning disability called this graph here. Not long after that she was in a meeting with her teachers, her parents and some special
我走到她那里看看能不能得到一些帮助。霍姆格伦小姐意识到发生了什么，她说我拼写似乎处于二年级水平，因为我当时在三年级。我说我觉得我拼写更像是幼儿园水平。我认为在那一刻和其他时刻，她意识到发生的事情不仅仅是典型的写作问题。莱拉做了一些测试，她被诊断出患有一种名为“书写障碍”的学习障碍。不久之后，她和她的老师、父母以及一些特殊
led instructors to figure out what to do next. This was honestly quite terrifying because I was just a small child and all these people were there gathered around me talking about me and it was pretty scary. We were all sitting around a long table and Mrs. Holmgren pulled out a computer and opened it to Google Docs and said that there was this cool thing that she wanted to show me. So she showed me how to open speech to text and I did not quite understand what this was at first. Then she showed me that you talked to the computer and it writes down what you're saying. This was just an overwhelming moment for me because I realized all of the stories and the ideas that I had stuck in my head, there was an easy way to get them down on the paper and to be able to share them with the world.
教育指导员开了一个会，商量下一步该怎么做。这老实说非常可怕，因为我只是个小孩子，所有这些人都在那里围着我谈论我，这很吓人。我们都坐在长桌旁，霍姆格伦夫人拿出一台电脑，打开谷歌文档，说有一件很酷的事情她想给我看。于是她向我展示了如何打开语音转文字功能，我起初不太明白这是什么。然后她向我展示了你对着电脑说话，它就会写下你所说的话。这对当时的我来说是一个压倒性的时刻，因为我意识到我脑子里卡住的所有故事和想法，有一种简单的方法可以把它们写在纸上，并能够与世界分享。
And I just threw my head back and said, I could write a thousand stories. It was just an amazing moment. And my parents were there, the teachers were there. And everybody seems to be thinking, yes, this is going to work. Like, we've made a difference. I still use speech-detached daily. I use it to send messages. I use it to write essays in class. I use it to type up emails. And she uses it to write stories.
我当时向后仰着头说，我可以写出一千个故事。那真是一个美妙的时刻。我的父母在场，老师们也在场。每个人似乎都觉得，是的，这行得通。就像我们已经做出了改变。我至今每天都在使用语音转文字功能。我用它发送信息，在课堂上写文章，输入电子邮件。而她用它来写故事。
Like the one she wrote a few years ago in fourth grade. I wrote a story called The Girl Who couldn't stop reading a K-A-A-Me and it was featured on a podcast called Story Pirates where kids write shows and then they turn them into radio plays so that was pretty cool. If Mrs. Holmgren was standing in front her today, this is what Lila would say. Thank you for noticing my potential and noticing that there was so much more to me and that it wasn't just the basic struggle that I was having. Not only did you notice the handwriting and help me get better at that, but you knew that there was so much inside my head that needed to get out.
就像她几年前四年级时写的那篇。我写了一个故事叫《那个无法停止阅读的女孩》，它在播客《故事海盗》上播出，那个节目让孩子们写剧本，然后把它们改编成广播剧，所以那真的很酷。如果霍姆格伦老师今天站在她面前，莱拉会这样说：谢谢您发现了我的潜力，意识到我远不止于此，我所经历的不仅仅是基础的挣扎。您不仅注意到了我的书写问题并帮助我改进，而且您知道我的脑海里有太多东西需要表达出来。
And to this day, I continue to expand and to great stories and just to get those things out of my head using voice to text. This segment was brought to you by OnStar. OnStar believes everyone has the right to feel safe everywhere. That's why their emergency advisors are now available to help not only in the car but wherever you are. On your phone, in your car and at home. OnStar. Be safe out there. If you're enjoying our YouTube.io series, please consider making a donation to support our work. You can do so at support.hiddenbrain.org.
直到今天，我仍在继续扩展和创作精彩的故事，并利用语音转文字功能将脑海中的想法表达出来。本节目由OnStar赞助播出。OnStar坚信每个人都有权在任何地方感到安全。这就是为什么他们的紧急顾问现在不仅可以在车内，还可以在任何地方为您提供帮助。无论是在手机上、车里还是家里。OnStar，祝您平安。如果您喜欢我们的YouTube.io系列节目，请考虑捐款支持我们的工作。您可以访问support.hiddenbrain.org进行捐赠。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。再见。目前本集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。